let me jump to the story so for all
those that are concerned we have this
story from timcast.com conservative
dad's Ultra right beer introduced
combating Dylan Mulvaney's sponsorship
by Bud Light to the rest of you woke
corporations stay the F away from our
kids now I want to say two things one
well I'll say three things first I am
not promoting or encouraging anyone to
buy this beer it's an alcoholic product
I'm not big on beer but now you know it
exists so do have your own volition I
will also say it is good that
conservatives are creating Alternatives
by whatever means necessary to compete
with these uh
with these woke corporations creating a
market opportunity to say hey you're
worried about what beer you might buy
here's a beer that you don't got to
worry about but more importantly it's
what Seth weathers who co-founded this
said stay the F away from our kids so
when Howard Stern said I don't
understand why Kid Rock is so mad it's
not nobody nobody screamed and cried at
least to this degree because Coors put a
pride flag ad out and said Miller core
supports LGBT Pride they sell tons of
beer in gay neighborhoods nobody cried
about that it's been going on for
general for for two three generations or
whatever there can they're angry that
people like Del Mulvaney Target children
and the corporations are targeting
children and I'll just say it's twofold
why is a beer company sponsoring an
individual's primary audience is
teenagers
that's just like didn't we have this
huge thing about Joe Camel and cartoons
marketing cigarettes to kids
those are awesome the VP did say she
wants a younger audience she wants young
people to drink or the brand would quote
die and that to me in itself that to me
well whether it's a lie or not it's
still coming from a mentality of I want
young kids to drink beer which is
absolutely horrible for them horrible
for their cognitive function there's
some studies even showing how people in
their 20s have their brains still
developing so to have that skewed and
manipulated and heard in so many
different ways by alcohol that's
something else that should be called out
here and instead of saying hey let's
drink another beer hey don't drink that
poison at all it's full of uh endocrine
disruptors it's filled with fluoride
it's filled with horrible substances
that are really bad for you and I think
this is an opportunity to say hey I'm
not going to poison myself and let's not
poison each other either let's make an
alternative better choice for ourselves
well look I I agree I don't drink beer I
think beer is bad but I think the
overall majority of human beings on the
planet love beer and beer is actually
responsible for him human civilization
as it is do you guys know this yeah with
the with the water and the bacteria in
there no no I mean that's true too but
the issue was that humans were nomadic
until we discovered the beer making
process or a rudimentary form of it and
then we had to stop moving around so
that the beer could ferment we liked
beer so much we were like let's just
stick around here and grow more of this
stuff to make more of that stuff and so
that's I don't know if it's true it's
urban legend or whatever they say that
beer was the beginning of Agriculture
for us because we were like yo this
stuff makes me feel good and so we want
to make more of it so I think beer is
great I think there are a lot of people
that understand drinking heavily is bad
for you but crack and open a cold one
with the boys after a long hard day of
work you show up to the to the bar or
whatever and you grab an ice cold an ice
cold Ultra right
and then you're just relaxing with
everybody and you're and you're you know
you know ripping each other and you're
having a good time I can certainly
understand why people enjoy that moment
and I think it's fairly obvious as to
why this story became so big it's
because
let me slow down and put it this way
like eight like five years ago I said
sooner or later the woke stuff will come
to Major League Sports and
people will start to understand what it
really is the rules of the NBA are
arbitrary we made them up it's a social
construct we decided where the where the
free throw line is we decided how many
players are on a team and we could
decide that half the team should be
women
and that will happen now it's happening
in the other direction it's happening to
women's teams first but I I said this
was going to happen
I thought that when it got to the point
where someone like Colin Kaepernick
would kneel or the NFL would be forced
to have half of their football team be
women that's when you'd see a major
Revolt because regular people love
sports and all that but while sports did
play a big role with people being upset
it didn't go that far I should have made
the obvious prediction beer you screw
with dude's beer and they're gonna lose
it and now you got a bunch of regular
guys being like why is my beer gay you
know and now they're asking that
question and it's spreading and the
morality of it still has to be
considered here because if you're Dylan
Mulvaney right and you look at your Tick
Tock you're like oh what's my analytics
who am I reaching who am I talking to
who's my core audience I'll bet you're
uh you know I'll bet a lot of money
right now that's probably a lot of
underage children and then to say hey
hey kids look at me drink some beer have
fun that's ridiculous that's absolutely
disgusting that's something that should
have been called out here by the
mainline Society saying hey
um even even but you know Anheuser-Busch
should have said who's the core audience
here why are we trying to advertise to
small children for an alcoholic beverage
that will stunt their cognitive function
and growth that right there should be
the conversation in the discussion and
is repundant and disgusting in its in
its in its face this is what I was going
to bring up earlier I believe that it's
illegal for beer commercials on TV to
show people drinking the beer in the
commercial allowed to hold it and show
it and have it but if they actually
drink it the it's become Elite as far as
I know that's illegal but in this
somehow because it's on the internet
they're allowed to that it should be it
should be a violation that's illegal you
can't you can't deal them with any was
sipping that thing in the bathtub in
that commercial
I looked it up I looked it up apparently
uh the average age of a tick tock user
is just under 21 years old so you have
an individual who is whose primary
audience and I believe Donald's audience
is probably younger than that the reason
why the average age of a tick tock user
is just under 21 is because you have to
factor in the amount of people who are
older than that and how it averages out
in the age that means it's probably I
would say the median age the plurality
of users are probably around 16 17 maybe
18 years old you then have a smaller uh
portion which are probably in their late
30s 40s or whatever
and then it averages out and it pulls up
the average age a little bit making it
sound like the average person who get is
older when in actuality the majority of
users are probably well under 21. I
don't think you've I think Don
Mulvaney's audience is probably 14 15.
and that's and Tick Tock is targeting
these these kids intentionally and
you're a role model you're you're a role
model for a lot of younger individuals
and the same let's be honest here it
goes for Joe Rogan if you take a can of
beer and you open it you're inspiring
other people to do that as well and and
some people may say oh you're making too
much of a big deal of it but little
things like that little Impressions like
that absolutely matter especially with
what you endorse what you drink and how
many people look up to you as a role
model as you're going to have a lot of
people copying you and and those are
decisions that I think people should be
thinking about seriously if they're you
know influencers but why can't we why
can't we accept and I know you probably
do but why can't we accept that that's
why they do it they know they're Role
Models they know well I I I believe the
right is finally getting better at
waking up as we realize what horrible
anti-human scum these people are they're
after your kids on purpose they're
they're on Nick Jr for a reason they're
on Tick Tock to 15 year olds for a
reason they're on Disney for a reason
they didn't trip and oh whoops I'm at
Disney
they're after your kids on purpose oh
let me elaborate elaborate real quick
real quick
um when we're talking about mastectomies
for children when they when they're
giving young girls mastectomies we
actually looked up the stats and it's in
the thousands I believe it's like in the
over the past few years it's like a
couple thousand and the left will say
something like why do you care so much
it doesn't happen then why was it I
think it was Blue's Clues which is a
children's show depicted a character
with mastectomy scars why would they
want kids to see that well I believe it
was uh let me make sure I can I can look
this up and get it right I think it was
on Blues Clues there was a pride event
showing characters with mastectomy scars
so all Divi correction while you're
doing that uh it's not illegal to show
people drinking beer on TV it's highly
uh frowned upon by the agency television
agencies since it's like a post
prohibition thing I was told a long time
ago that it was illegal and that's why
we don't see it but apparently it's just
a voluntary thing that they don't so
look at this here you go Snopes did
Blues Clues Pride Parade feature a
beaver with top scars true that's from
Snopes now why are they showing your
children Pride parades with people with
top scars the issue is I may not be
like when they come out and they say
something like oh not that many kids are
getting it you're exaggerating it's like
I never came out and said every kid was
getting it this is the weird thing when
Joe when Matt Walsh was on Joe Rogan and
Rogan asked Matt Walsh how many kids are
doing this Matt Walsh what did he say
millions or something like that
uh he said some ridiculous number and
then everyone called him out because
it's thousands it's a it's in terms of
cross-sex hormones I think it's around
50 000 in terms of puberty blockers it's
like 17 000 and in terms of uh
mastectomies for for uh adolescent girls
it's in the thousands like between one
and two thousand and I was like well I
don't I can't speak for anybody else but
I never came out and said oh heavens me
so many there's too many kids getting
this it must be in the millions I was
like one kid getting this is not good
and you know why because in Scandinavia
they piloted this and then said whoa
this isn't working and abandoned it and
in the UK they piloted this and then
said whoa this is not working and
abandon it and not only were the
children that they were trying to treat
still suicidal or or depressed the
surgeries and the and the medical
intervention actually increased or or
made these things worse or did nothing
at all thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time